John Barry here on the Rich Eisen show
part of the coverage part and parcel
worldwide leader in sports how are you
John what do you say rich this is great
I'm opening for Johnny Knoxville
you are indeed you are indeed what is
that what's the most dangerous what's
the what's the what's the thing you love
about not so John I just love the movie
I mean the stuff that they do is just
it's I don't understand how I can come
up with the stuff they come up with it's
amazing what's the most dangerous thing
you've ever done
well intentionally or unintentionally
all right let's start with
unintentionally falling off the high
dives the wrong way and hitting the
pavement rather than the pool oh my god
whoa yeah that was pretty good how long
of a drop was that John well I know one
of those 12 12 feet or so jeast how old
were you here six what yeah right under
the grill oh my gosh were you
hospitalized on that Chuck I I wasn't
actually my my dad actually was playing
tennis nearby and heard the scream and
ran up there and grabbed me and I don't
remember where I went from there oh I
didn't just tell you to just you know
[Laughter]
then what about intentionally uh I don't
know I mean I would say like some cliff
jumping or something on yeah I'm not
really that much of a danger seeker well
I mean you're a professional athlete for
a very long time so you don't want to
you don't want to mess with that
moneymaker in a way let's let's talk
about this game I just threw it out
there game ones the best shot that
they're gonna have in oakland what do
you think yeah I guess I would agree
that it's their best shot I don't know
that I particularly liked the shot I
just did the whole Eastern Conference
series and LeBron is incredible we all
know this and it's just amazing that
night after night that you just you you
just know what you're gonna you're gonna
get greatness I mean the guy doesn't
disappoint I mean I guess you
look at Game five in that last series
where he only had 26 and 10 rebounds as
his worst game where he was legitimately
tired and then to back it up with 46 in
games 635 in game 7 on the road in
victories we know what we're gonna get
out of him he's going to be great it's
the others that is my concern and when
they're bad they're very bad they should
sub 30% in the three-point line they
shoot sub 40 percent from the field and
they don't score many points and you can
pencil LeBron in for whatever you want
if these other guys don't play and
contribute they're not going to be able
to score enough to beat the words
because the Warriors are going to score
against this Cleveland defense yeah I
know I mean you have to figure they're
gonna at least not go home for twenty
seven from three-point range before we
continue on in the NBA Finals a
conversation I got to get my you know
thoughts of a shooter John I mean 27
straight mysteries how the hell did that
happen amazing you know what most of
them were quality looks now I know
they've started pressing you know
probably down the stretch a little bit
but I mean stone-cold wide open looks
and you know people say well if you're
missing that many shots why'd he keep
doing well that's who you are that's how
they've been all season and to think
that that could happen but I saw some
one in 72,000 that that could
potentially happen or something uh it's
just it's it's crazy me to think that
they think that that would happen no one
could ever think that and I don't blame
Houston that's the way they play and you
know unfortunately for them they did
make I guess the old axiom lived by the
three and die by the three and they they
fell on that sword man I just still
can't believe it
27 in a row Ariza going old for a dozen
breaking but breaking the all-time
record for most attempts without a make
and and they had him I mean he had two
warriors kind of dead to rights right
there now defensively they were
switching like crazy and made the
Warriors look on offense a way that we
haven't seen anybody else do you think
the Cavs can pull pull that off they
have the I don't I give Houston a ton of
credit with the way they played the
switching certainly did cause Golden
State a bunch of problems and
well by the way if you switch everything
everyone says why is why is going to
stay playing ISO ball well you have to
play isolation bowl if you switch
everything there's really nothing else
you can do you're just going to try to
find the best matchup that you can and
then you're gonna hope that that guy can
beat that guy and what happened was was
Houston wasn't helping off on all Golden
State drives what typically happens in
the regular season or when you play poor
teams they help and then they kick it
you know let's say Steph Curry's going
to the lane they help off off of klay
Thompson in the corner and he kicks it
to him and he makes a three and it
happens time and time and time again and
that just wasn't happening because
Houston decided not to do any helping so
that's much what we're gonna see tonight
everybody switches every pick-and-roll
but I don't think Cleveland has the
personnel that Houston does on the
defensive end to be able to stop this
about John Barry here on the Rich Eisen
show it's interesting use the phrase the
others for those who remember the the
pop-culture phrase the others
unfortunately for Cleveland it's from
the movie from the TV show Lost was a
good movie - yeah what about Wahlberg
and Will Ferrell what's land of the lost
I think is what you might be or so not
that one no wasn't it the others I see
what you're going so when it comes to
the others we saw the others look superb
against Toronto and then Jeff green
stepped up from that group of others
when love was out love is back now who
do you think has the matchup
favorability for to be the other to step
up here John just with those two or who
anybody know on the matchups now we've
seen it three times before but EGH with
dollars out that's what I'm saying
tonight might be their best shot who do
you think from the others can suddenly
gaze at jr. Smith that setup to have
something positive happened final year
junior struggled mightily you know what
the key to me just watching them over
the last seven games was George Hill
when George Hill plays aggressive when
he takes shots early in the game they're
a different team and he averaged double
figures at home
didn't play quite as well on the road
but I think there's a confidence level
from George Hill now that that I think
he was a bit tentative but you know when
you come on come over and play with
LeBron James it's his show he's got the
ball you kind of maybe you're looking
over your shoulder whether you should
take shots be aggressive
you have to deferred in LeBron all the
time and I think he finally got to a
comfort level like where he saw that
this team is a better team when he plays
aggressively and I think George Hill is
is a kind of a barometer for Cleveland
he's got to get off to start early and
be aggressive and he can make shots I
think that's a big thing for Cleveland
have you noticed I'm just trying I'm
trying to figure out a storyline here
where you say the Cleveland Cavaliers
have a chance give it to me why do you
want Cleveland is this I mean no I don't
hold on a second know what I'm what I'm
saying is I don't want to see four in a
row and I don't want to see four out of
five I'd like to see this stretch to six
I'd like to see it go back to Cleveland
so they've got an opportunity to maybe
take it to a game seven or see what it
looks like when when LeBron knows it's
entirely possible that he's done there
in Cleveland with the fans giving him
that sort of appreciation I'd like to
see that rather than that moment
happened with a four-game sweep quite
honestly John yeah yeah I don't think
it's gonna be four games I mean when you
got a guy like LeBron James look I don't
think it's as big as mismatch as people
are making it out to be
look Golden State not as dominant they
went sixteen and one last year and
warriors in the playoffs they're 12 and
5 right now they're they're not the same
team for whatever the reason may be the
way people are defending them I don't
know what it is but they're not the same
team and Cleveland came back from 3-1
and 2016
LeBron the Bron knows what he needs
Moses they know this team tyronn lue
understands what has to happen to beat
this warrior team so I'm stunned until
12 or 13 point line whatever it is and
game on I just think that's a ton of
points and before I let you go what do
you think the Rockets should do they've
got a Chris Paul a Paul contract sitting
right there
and it's entirely possible that they
could entice a free agent to come a free
note potentially the one that we've
already had a conversation about during
this during this hit here John what do
you think the rocket should do after a
65 win season ending the way it did yeah
I think it's tough I mean Chris Paul's
33 wants five years you're paying him
two hundred million dollars that that's
that's tough to swallow when you're
sitting there four or five years down
the road and he's making forty five
forty ml I don't think there's a major
tweak that needs to happen I don't think
it has to be a LeBron James or a Paul
George that has to go there I think it's
got to be a guy that can stand there and
shoot shots and play defense I don't
think that you need another guy that
wants to hold the basketball you already
have two guys that do that so it's not
much I think it's a player that doesn't
have to be an all-star type player that
could maybe Houston over the top do you
have a burner Twitter account John I
know you don't have a recognize no tweet
for me but you're not even you're not
even on just to see what's what's
happening you don't even have that was
constantly I'm I'm old my kids tell me
I'm a loser and okay so what do you
think is going on in that Sixers locker
room right now with the new man I'm with
clay I mean I don't see I don't know the
Twitter world I mean is this guy nailed
or what I mean I read where he he's he
definitely copped to one of the five
said four of the other five were not him
but was initially told of only two and
the three other ones to come up with a
five went from went from public to
private meaning you're not allowed to
look at the tweets unless the person
allows you to overnight it so somebody
something got alert so some way with the
ringer alerting the Sixers to ask Alicia
first to shut down three other ones
unless that's completely coincidental
and then and then the one of the two
that was not shut down that he said was
told about and said it wasn't his was
found to be tweeting during some of his
press conferences so there is an alibi
if you will there well the one who
wasn't one of them his son or he's
throwing his son out of the bus well
he's not throwing anybody under the bus
he's saying he has no idea about the
other ones but there is now
rumor that it could be a family member
who was tweeting some of this
proprietary information out unbeknownst
to him or or known to him I don't know
he said he knew nothing about it John
Wow
okay wait does I see how this one turns
out okay
United you're not a social media guy at
all then I'm not I don't really do it
okay John what like why would anybody
care what I'm doing I don't care my kids
don't care like so why would you care if
I'm not saying now I'm not saying hey
I'm going to pick up you know some of my
gluten free food for my for my diet I'm
not saying that exciting but what I'm
saying is like you would then say you
would be giving opinions about game one
during game on that is what I'm saying
it's four right okay you know that's
fine but I get myself in trouble if I
you know you gotta count to ten before
you press then hover you have to hover
that thumb man before you get yeah
there's no question I agree all right
John Knoxville is settled on to the
green room couch right now oh well do
you want to right there John bad you
want to say something a Knoxville go for
it John much respect big fan there you
go he's got respect for each other oh
thank you much respect to you do you
have an idea who John Berry is Johnny
it's okay John Bear is he part of the
basketball berries yes yes yeah it's a
great basketball family I know who he is
Wow take care John later you guys John
Bower everybody when I had John voice
when we got Jon Voight on through Steven
Bowers phone right we played phone
rolodex with Steven Bauer and we got Jon
Voight on live and I'm like hey John I
just want to say hello right that was
kind of close to that moment right there
that was his response right there
good to see you Knoxville how you doing
brother good to see you Johnny Knoxville
sitting here on the Rich Eisen show
green room couch
chin point in theaters near you starting
tomorrow funny movie will show you a
clip for the TV audience and then a chat
with Knoxville when we come back the
Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern
on audience